ايوه بس هو مش مش قلب مقدس خلي بالك ان ده
شيء مرن يتغير مع العصر فاحنا النهارده
همم
الناس مثلا الشباب الصغير اللي هو المفروض
اسرع منك ومني طبعا انا عشان اكبر منك
بكثير بس يعني مني ومنك ماشي دول السماره
الاصغر بقى ايه اللي خلاه يقعد يتفرج على
في في البراسات مثلا على الحلقه ساعه
المنطق بيقول لو مش هنا المنطق السوري
يعني اللي هو كانه واحد زائد اثنين وخلاص
لا ممكن جدا يبقى المنطق السوري يقول لك
انت المفروض الشباب ده عايز يتفرج على خمس
دقائق عشر دقائق
لانه انه يقول لك بدل تتفرج على حلقات
كثير
وبشاره على الموبايل
لانه التسريع هنا مهمه يعني
بياخذ بايدك واحيانا بيدي لك حكمه في
الحياه مش حكمه عشان واحد ماسك جواب
بقراءه ويقول لك هذه الرساله وانا الاستاذ
الكبير بيقول لك على القديم